Aquí tengo este vehículo que recorre 150 km en 3 horas,
lo que quiero que veamos es encontrar
una forma razonable
para describir la rapidez de este vehículo
durante este tiempo.
Los invito a que pausen el video y piensen en ello.
Una vez que encontremos la rapidez veremos que hay formas de expresarla razonables y no tan razonables.
Primero recordemos qué es la rapidez.
Tenemos que la distancia es igual a la
rapidez por el tiempo.
Si dividimos ambos lados de esta
igualdad entre el tiempo,
nos va a quedar distancia
entre tiempo...
esto entre tiempo...
estos se van, nos queda que la distancia entre el tiempo
es igual a la rapidez, nos dan la distancia, nos dan el tiempo, pues solo nos queda hacer la operación,
dividir la distancia entre el tiempo, aquí quiero conservar las unidades, ya que es muy importante
reconocer que las unidades, hasta cierto punto,
se pueden manipular de manera algebraica.
Recordemos que no son variables, pero siguen las mismas reglas de una variable,  por ejemplo,
la rapidez es igual a la distancia, la distancia nos dicen que son 150 km entre el tiempo, el tiempo son 3 horas.
Si vemos la parte numérica, 150 entre 3,
nos va a dar 50, la rapidez va a ser igual a 50.
Ahora veamos las unidades,
¿qué unidades tengo?
Tengo kilómetros entre horas, kilómetros por hora, esta es una forma razonable de expresar la rapidez.
A esto es a lo que me refería cuando mencioné
que podemos realizar la operación numérica
y también dejar las unidades de esta manera como estaban antes, mantenerlas de manera algebraica.
En un momento verán que podemos
manipularlas aun más,
usando lo que se conoce como  análisis dimensional.
Esta es una manera razonable de expresar la
rapidez, puedo imaginar que en una hora,
este auto recorre 50 km, pensemos en otras maneras
que podemos representar esto.
Ahora haremos un análisis dimensional, quedamos
que son 50 km por hora, digamos que ahora
quiero expresarlo en km por segundo,
¿cómo podemos hacer esto?
Reflexionemos en lo siguiente, si yo recorro
esto en una hora,
¿cuánto podré recorrer en un segundo, más o menos?
Los segundos son un periodo de tiempo
mucho más corto.
Hay 3600 segundos en una hora, así que recorreremos
uno entre 3600 partes de esta distancia,
pero veamos cómo se comporta viendo las unidades,
queremos deshacernos de estas horas,
que se encuentran en el denominador, de manera que
tendré que multiplicar esto por algo que
tenga horas en el numerador.
Y a donde quiero llegar es a tener km por segundo,
necesito tener segundos aquí abajo,
¿a cuántos segundos es igual una hora?
Si yo tengo aquí una hora, tendré 3600 segundos
en esa hora, a esto es a lo que me refería
con que al hacer el análisis dimensional
como lo estamos haciendo, podemos manipular
las unidades como variables algebraicas.
En este caso tengo horas en el numerador,
horas en este denominador y me va a quedar
que esto es igual a 50 por 1 entre 3600...
50 por 1 entre 3600, esta es la parte numérica.
Ahora, ¿qué nos queda en las unidades?
Pues solo tenemos kilómetros y segundos...
kilómetros por segundo.
Y esto no es tan intuitivo, aquí iríamos
1 entre 3600 veces, en un segundo lo que serían
50 en una hora y esto no es tan intuitivo,
vamos a hacer la operación,
simplifiquemos esto.
Lo voy a escribir aquí arriba, 50 por 1 = 50,
entre 3600, puedo quitar estos 0, me queda
5 entre 360, esto no lo puedo simplificar
tan directo, pero si puedo multiplicar el
numerador y el denominador por 2,
esto me quedaría 5 por 2 = 10, 360 por 2 serían
720 y aquí puedo quitar este 0 y éste de acá.
Me queda 1 entre 72, así que esto es igual
a 1/72 de km por segundo.
Esto está bastante difícil de visualizar,
puedo afirmar que estas no son unas unidades
razonables para este ejemplo en particular,
1/72 de km por segundo, pues no nos ayuda
mucho a imaginar la rapidez de este vehículo.
Hagamos la operación, sacamos la calculadora
y escribimos 1 entre 72, nos da 0.013... redondeamos
a 9... esto es igual a 0.0139 de km por segundo,
está bastante extraña esta unidad.
Realmente no me puedo imaginar esto.
Yo digo que este 50 km por hora,
es una forma muy buena de representar la rapidez, porque me permite imaginar recorrer 50 km en una hora.
Pero ¿qué pasaría si busco dejar esto en términos de una unidad más grande?
como por ejemplo metros por segundo.
Quedamos entonces que es 0.0139 km por segundo.
Ahora lo quiero dejar en metros por segundo,
sabemos que un km es igual a 1000 metros.
Si pensamos en esto en términos de metros
por segundo, tendremos aquí un número más
grande, más grande de hecho por un factor
de 1000 y trataremos de convertir estos km a metros.
¿Cómo lo puedo hacer?
Si tenemos km en el numerador deberemos tener
km en el denominador de lo que multipliquemos
1 km y aquí arriba quiero tener metros,
¿cuántos metros hay en un kilómetro?
Pues hay 1000 metros...
1000 metros... Pues tratando estas unidades como variables algebraicas,
puedo cancelar estos km de acá con estos de acá y quedarme con estas unidades
de metro por segundo y tengo que hacer esta operación numérica, de esto multiplicarlo por esto.
Esto es igual...
.0139 por 1000 vamos a mover el punto decimal
3 lugares a la derecha
y nos va a quedar 13.9 metros por segundo.
Esto lo puedo imaginar sin problema,
sé cuantos son 13.9 metros y que estos
se recorran en un segundo.
Ésta también es una manera razonable de
expresar la rapidez, puedo imaginar este vehículo
recorriendo 50 km en una hora, o casi 14 metros
en un segundo, pero 1/72 de km por segundo,
no es razonable en lo absoluto.
De hecho, si quisiera imaginar metros por hora, tampoco sería fácil de visualizar, vamos a hacerlo.
Tomemos nuestros 50 km por hora y a esto lo vamos a multiplicar por 1000 metros que hay en un km,
esos km se van, multiplico 50 por 1000 y me queda 50000 metros por hora
y este es un número muy grande y esta descripción
de la rapidez no parece muy útil,
ya que no me permite imaginar o visualizar esta rapidez,
al igual que tenerlo en km por segundo.